what's going on guys this is Rob and you
asked me to cover the story where
Warhawk fights Juggernaut so we're
covering it here so this story opens up
with what is one of the most iconic
moments in the Incredible Hulk's Mythos
when he subdued by the villain
apocalypse no doubt you've probably seen
this image circulating across the
internet so the reason he's able to do
this is because one apocalypse is one of
the most powerful beings in the entirety
of the Marvel Universe and two he's that
powerful because he managed to harness
Celestial technology so he can basically
give himself any superhuman power which
includes the ability to overpower The
Incredible Hulk now the Hulk himself
agrees to hear what apocalypse has to
say because apocalypse is talking about
turning the Hulk into one of his
Horsemen specifically the horsemen War
basically that means that the Incredible
Hulk would go forward in the world and
do apocalypse's bidding but the reason
why the Hulk even agrees to this is
because of two things the first is that
he's got some shrapnel in his head that
he's trying to get rid of and the second
is is because apocalypse will help the
Incredible Hulk eliminate the illusions
of his father Brian Banner which are
really more ghosts than anything else
the reason why this is happening is just
because of the fact that during the
Peter David run of the Incredible Hulk
he focused heavily on the idea that
Bruce was abused by his father so that
really kind of comes home to roost but
the important thing is that by using
Celestial technology on the Incredible
Hulk it augments his already incredibly
vast strength and then using a
specialized helmet it blocks out the
ghost of Brian Banner allowing Hulk to
live some measure of peace or at the
very least to move away from this
illusion and so the next time we see him
is when you have Rick Jones and Janus
and absori man Crusher creel Rick Jones
and Janice are really important to this
you're literally just going to see them
running around musing from time to time
and just trying not to get killed but
Crusher creel is important absorbing man
is in fact one of the most powerful
beings in Marvel because he can absorb
any material and that becomes his skin
so if you you want to touch the
adamantium of Wolverine he would become
adamantium it's crazy how powerful this
guy is but when the Hulk reappears he's
warholk now in this fight against
absorbing man there's not a whole lot
doing and in fact it ends with a
quickness it ends so incredibly fast and
this guy's taken out immediately but
following that the Juggernaut steps in
now the reason why these guys are even
involved here in the first place is
because of an organization called the
New World Order it's basically a group
ran by The Red Skull that's trying to
conquer the world but with apocalypse
making the Incredible Hulk his Horseman
War this would allow apocalypse to
conquer the world so literally two
groups who want to conquer the world are
trying to defeat each other so the other
one can conquer the world instead so
Juggernaut being here is for the purpose
of preventing that from happening the
other part of this is Juggernaut was
brought in by Apocalypse in order to
test the powers of the Incredible Hulk
with this new Celestial technology and
this fight is brutal but in one of the
most amazing moments in the entirety of
the story and really one of the most
iconic moments in the Incredible Hulk as
the Juggernaut gets his hands on him and
the Juggernaut starts pushing him
eventually Warhawk is able to stop
Juggernaut in his tracks that never
happens and in fact one of the main
Mythos aspects of Juggernaut is once he
starts moving he cannot be stopped with
the exception of somebody who's able to
lift him off the ground using whatever
power they have to achieve that there's
no discernible means of stopping this
guy and outside of this story I'm not
aware of any instance where Juggernaut
has been stopped like this even during
the events of world war Hulk The
Incredible Hulk himself just diverted
the momentum of Juggernaut it's one of
the reasons why people make the argument
that warholk is stronger than World
breaker Hulk but regardless of how you
decide to slice it Juggernaut gets
overpowered and just sent flying I mean
it's crazy because one of the things
that happens here and this is
morally questionable at best their whole
fight ends up destroying a mosque they
destroy a house of worship
and I'm not quite sure how I feel about
that but it's a knock down drag out
fight between the two because understand
this conflict is such that most any and
all Heavy Hitters in Marvel Comics
outside of somebody like Hyperion or the
century or blue Marvel or Juggernaut
they would never stand a chance in this
conflict it's pretty intense now it does
also wrap up fairly fast in the sense
that Warhawk gets the upper hand on
Juggernaut readily and easily that's
just how capable this guy is and so when
he has Juggernaut pinned down he uses a
sword pops off his helmet and then kind
of makes fun of it right in answering
the question so nothing can stop the
Juggernaut huh well there's two things
that can do that my power and your
imminent beheading and understand he
would kill Kane Marco now something else
to understand here is that this is Kane
Marco fighting at his Peak right this is
him using every ounce of strength he had
because during this point in time this
takes place in the aftermath of the
onslaught Saga why does that matter
that's the storyline where Onslaught
punched the Juggernaut across the world
so this is one of those instances where
he just goes into fights giving his all
every single time despite the fact that
he's terrified of Warhawk now as
Juggernaut is about to die the absorbing
man pops back in again and is able to at
least momentarily get the upper hand on
Warhawk if for no other reason than a
distraction but between these two guys
right Juggernaut and the absorbing man
Crusher creel they still can't beat
Warhawk they still can't defeat this guy
that's how powerful he is but there does
come a point when Rick Jones steps in
and for the first time in the story
becomes useful and actually gets smacked
by Warhawk into a wall it's not enough
to kill him but it is enough to severely
injure him and the result of this is
that the ghost of Brian Banner suddenly
manifests what this means is that
warholk is basically losing the war
Persona and the traditional Incredible
Hulk is starting to manifest again but
as this whole experience starts to wear
on him he realizes that by virtue of his
actions he almost killed his best friend
and ultimately tears everything off of
himself and then just jumps away and
then the story ends with that being said
guys we're going to bring this to an end
if you enjoyed this video make sure you
drop a like and I will catch you all
later
peace